ever since my video about tether and
june which is a cryptocurrency company
worth 60 billion dollars and growing
i've been trying to do one of two things
to expose them as frauds or prove that
they've turned legit i feel i have to
after all if you believe something this
big might be a fraud you owe it to
people to try to find out for sure so
i've been racking my brain how do you
find out something like this for sure
and then
i had an idea ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million studio i'm
your host coffee zilla the internet
detective so
tether was investigated by the new york
attorney general office already right we
know this they settled and as part of
this investigation they had to hand over
thousands of documents but we ultimately
only got to see a small report out of
all those thousands of pages that they
looked at and i started to wonder could
it be that some of the answers we've
been looking for are maybe somewhere in
the middle between investigation and the
ultimate settlement report that they put
out maybe those documents hold the key
but of course you might be saying well
that sounds great but that's locked up
by the government right stephen
wrong
see i remembered something called the
freedom of information act which lets
you request public government documents
and with some exceptions usually they
have to hand them over if you ask i
actually have used the freedom of
information act in the past to
investigate a criminology department
case at florida state university but
that's a story for another day the point
is you can get insane amounts of
information if you just ask so i started
to suspect given my history with that
that i could maybe do the same thing
with tether the investigation by the new
york attorney general was over after all
which should mean that it's in the
public record now so i decided to send a
formal request to new york state the
office of the attorney general now it
turns out their version of this is a bit
different they call it the freedom of
information law request but it's very
similar to foia which i've done before i
shoot off my request i shot my shot told
them what i wanted which was basically
everything and then just waited
[Music]
they told me in a few days that the
office of the attorney general
acknowledges receipt of the above
referenced foil request we are
performing a diligent search for the
records you request we will notify you
of the status of your request on or
before july 29th 2021 this was on june
30th so i just waited a few weeks and
that's when something i didn't expect
happened in summary they said nah not a
chance we're going to give that stuff to
you but of course it's in that very
professional jargon that they use please
be advised that records or portions of
records that respond to your above
reference foil request may be exempt
from disclosure pursuant to
provides that an agency may deny access
to records or portions thereof that are
trade secrets or are submitted to an
agency by a commercial enterprise or
derived from information obtained from
commercial enterprise and which
disclosed would cause substantial injury
to the competitive position of the
subject enterprise what the hell does
that mean
well basically they're saying we've got
we're coca-cola and the formula is in
these documents but i want to tell you
how full of crap this response is see
ladies and gentlemen i was expecting
some things to be retracted after all
when i did this in the past i got a lot
of documents that had retractions it's
not uncommon for there to be sensitive
information in documents and what you do
is this this is actually one of the
emails that i foia the black redaction
is basically preventing private info
sensitive info from leaking uh which is
you know fair play so imagine my shock
when they just say like yeah we're not
gonna send
anything well actually in technical
jargon speak this is what they actually
told me these particular documents will
be exempt from disclosure and kept apart
from all other records until 15 days
after the entitlement to such an
exception has been finally determined we
will notify you in such an exception has
been finally determined yeah they're
gonna notify me right uh that was a
month and a half ago to be clear that
i've been patiently waiting but
something finally broke my perfect
patience that i was practicing and that
was when i read this article exhibit a
your honor
tether asks court to block new york
attorney general from releasing
documents to not even coffeezilla to
coindesk ladies and gentlemen
our freedom of information law request
asked for the release of any documents
attesting to tether's reserve
composition again some very pertinent
information and in this we find out that
they did the same thing with coindesk
that they did with me not only that it
turns out it wasn't the attorney general
that was being difficult it was tether
apparently tether has been submitting
court orders in order to block this
information from leaky quote tether and
crypto exchange bitfinex has petitioned
the new york supreme court to block
coindesk and other organizations from
receiving documents detailing the
composition of tethers reserves over the
past few
years and yes that's one of the things
that i did ask for now what they
basically try to argue here is that
releasing these documents would harm
tether's competitive position in the
marketplace ladies and gentlemen and
ostensibly that's because they have this
like secret sauce in these documents but
uh this is total crap right the truth is
is that this was a public investigation
by the new york attorney general it's
finished now that information should be
released i mean that is the whole point
of foil or foia or whatever you want to
call it it's to find out what the
government knows same principle so that
we can hold them accountable and people
like tether who they investigate
accountable right now we aren't able to
do that journalists at coindesk aren't
able to do that and the question is why
i mean what could be so important that
you couldn't redact you have to
completely ban any of these documents
from getting out there i'll give you
guys my thoughts real quick here i don't
know what they're hiding specifically
but my guess is that they're right that
it would hurt them if it's leaked but
it's not because competitors would find
out what they've been doing i think it's
because the rest of us would find out
what they've been doing the story's not
over and seeing this report from
coindesk just made me realize that it
wasn't just me um that couldn't get
access to these documents tether seems
to be actively blocking these things
from getting to journalists such as the
ones at coindesk so yeah it's just
completely crazy i have a feeling that
they're going to be some huge
revelations soon because you cannot hide
these things forever so anyways thank
you guys so much for watching supporting
don't forget to pump the stock by
subscribing and liking it's absolutely
free and i will see you guys in the next
you'd one but
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as